[Music]
not commenting god
um oh my god uh i so when i was an
undergrad i once tried to explain to one
of my professors who was one of the
original authors of java
that python was self-documenting and so
i didn't need to comment my code
because python is so easy to read and he
just laughed at me he laughed for like
five minutes and was like get out of my
office
ah maybe it's like one indexing one
indexing is a pretty awful language
decision that i
really vehemently dislike
repetitive code i mean nobody wants to
see the same code written a thousand
times in a file
long code people reinventing the same
classes over and over again this is very
commonplace in the python and pytorch
community that
you know people are reinventing the pie
torch layers over and over and again and
um nobody wants to nobody wants to see
that and everyone just wants to use the
standard ones but for some reason nobody
does
maybe it's not really a source of misery
is debugging like
distributed things so when you have like
multiple nodes working together and
something's breaking somewhere
debugging stack traces of where that's
happening and reasoning across multiple
independent servers and all these like
race conditions is suffering
i really don't like it when people write
large blocks of code and no uh breakups
of creating functions and everything's
like modular modularization is so useful
uh because it helps break up little
concepts into um
into a format that's actually easy to
understand for people and also lack of
uh documentation that's that would be
two pet peeves of mine i think my
biggest pet peeve would be
lack of organization so
i guess particularly in code structure
like file layout and code structure so i
think uh
yeah sometimes you see
either just like a bunch of different
pieces of code all in like one directory
and there's no sort of like directory
layout or even within a given piece of
code uh there's yeah just not much
rhyme or reason to how the the structure
is laid out and sometimes it's sort of
just like the code you can clearly tell
the code like evolved as someone was
thinking and there wasn't much sort of
restructuring and so i think yeah lack
of organization makes it really hard to
go back and
either as a third party like understand
what someone was doing or even yourself
you know a year later trying to
understand your own code it's almost
like a different person
poor
documentation
i
like lack of comments and poor
documentation lack of explanation lack
of documentation around apis and like
yeah make it easy for me please
[Music]